-As they start to worry
about their midterm prospects,
Republicans are turning
to their favorite election-year
scare tactic by lying
about immigration,
highlighted by an especially
cruel and sadistic stunt
from Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis,
who claimed credit
for his scheme
to lie to a group
of undocumented migrants
and lure them onto a plane
that then dropped them off
on a remote island
where they didn't know anyone.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
An ironclad rule of modern
Republican politics
in the Trump era
is that in order to thrive
within the party,
you must have an unquenchable
thirst for embarrassment.
You have to be
a glutton for shame.
You have to be willing
to debase yourself
and endure any indignity
or humiliation
thrown your way
by Donald Trump.
That's the one thing his
cult-like inner circle
of criminal mutant gargoyles
all have in common.
There's just no amount
of [bleep] they won't eat
just to get invited to Trump's
haunted golf mansion
for the honor
of a photo op
with a man whose thumbs-up
looks so unnatural,
you wouldn't be surprised
if they had to lift it
into position using an elaborate
system of pulleys and levers.
"Is it time for the picture?
Let's get cranking, Eric!"
"Yes, father, yes!"
[ Laughter ]
"Faster, Eric.
I don't have all day."
[ Laughter ]
"We're losing the light, Eric!"
Ted Cruz threw his own family
under the bus for Trump.
Matt Gaetz reportedly asked him
for a pardon
in a sex-trafficking case.
And Rudy Giuliani
did a press conference
outside a landscaping company
near a crematorium
and a sex shop.
And you should have
seen his face
when he accidentally
walked into the sex shop.
"Whoa! These are some very
odd-looking microphones."
[ Laughter ]
Now, of course, we could've
Photoshopped this Rudy picture
screaming
into a dildo microphone,
but it wasn't fair,
so we didn't do it.
I mean, you can picture
what it would've looked like,
but that's on you.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't do it.
And now the most vivid example
of humiliating obsequiousness
to Trump is Ohio
Senate candidate J.D. Vance,
a Yale Law School graduate
and Silicon Valley
venture capitalist.
Vance was once
a relentless critic of Trump.
He called himself
a "Never Trump guy"
who said he couldn't stomach
Trump, called Trump noxious
and an idiot, even suggested
Trump could be America's Hitler.
Hell, Vance could've been
one of my writers.
In fact, he even
came on this show
and talked to me,
a cosmopolitan,
coastal elite, no less,
when he was hawking his book.
And no one who has
nice things to say
about Donald Trump
comes on this show.
I mean,
except for that one time
we did day drinking
with Mike Lindell.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's funny,
because his normal voice
is drunk guy at a bar
telling you how much
he loves you,
but his drunk voice --
it's so weird --
is British gentlemen.
"I have proof that
Hugo Chavez
hacked the Dominion
voting machines.
Now let's do some shots
and head over
to Makato Hardee's.
[ Laughter ]
But now Vance has cynically
retracted everything he said
about Trump to run for Senate.
And Trump has repaid
Vance's newfound loyalty
by both endorsing him
and also repeatedly
humiliating him.
At a rally a few months ago,
Trump forgot Vance's name
and then confused him
with one of Vance's
primary opponents,
first calling him
J.P. and then J.D. Mandel.
And then over the weekend,
Trump appeared at another rally
with Vance and again
took the opportunity to make
Vance eat [bleep]
for his own entertainment.
"The New York Times"
did a fake story today --
big front page --
that J.D. wasn't sure
if he wanted my support.
J.D. is kissing my ass
he wants my support so --
Yeah, he said
some bad things about me,
but that was before he knew me,
and then he fell in love.
"J.D. is a great guy.
Great guy.
Used to hate my guts,
but then he realized
he couldn't win without me.
So he changed his tune in order
to court my voters,
who he sees as gullible rubes.
That's you.
You're the rubes."
[ Laughter ]
And it's not just Trump
they've devoted themselves to
but Trumpism.
For example, when Vance
took the podium
at this rally on Saturday
and began to list
the various problems
he would address
as a senator from Ohio,
the first thing
he could apparently think of
was actually 1,500 miles away
from where he was speaking.
-We have got some problems
right now, ladies and gentlemen.
We've got some problems
on the southern border.
-The southern border of Ohio?
[ Laughter ]
You guys have a lot of problem
with refugees
from Kentucky streaming
across your border?
"You don't understand.
That place is dystopian.
Hell, we live under the thumb
of a ruthless dictator.
He calls himself the Colonel."
[ Laughter ]
No one's number-one problem
is that far away,
unless they're being catfished
as part of a fake
long-distance relationship.
"Yeah, I met this girl, Jessica,
who lives in Vancouver.
She's so great.
But, you know, it has --
It has been a drain financially.
I've been sending her money
for a surgery to have her
Getty watermark removed."
[ Laughter ]
It's one thing to say we should
fix the immigration system,
but Republicans are singularly
and obsessively
focused on the border.
For example,
there's this anecdote from 2018
that I'll never forget,
when Trump was obsessively
hyping up the so-called caravans
of migrants supposedly headed
for the border.
And "The New York Times"
reported that
"Trump's dystopian imagery
has clearly left an impression,
with some, including
a 75-year-old Republican
in northern Minnesota,
who said she was afraid
that migrant gangs could take
over people's summer lake homes
in the state.
'What's to stop them?
We have a lot of people
who live on lakes in the summer
and winter someplace else.
When they come back
in the spring,
their house would be occupied.'"
Yeah.
I mean, what is to stop them?
They could just waltz right
over the border into El Paso,
hop on a Greyhound bus,
ride that for three days,
break into a cabin
on a frozen lake
in northern Minnesota,
and catch Viking fever.
[ Laughter ]
I'll say if you live
in Minnesota
and leave your house
unoccupied for the winter,
you're much more likely
to come back
and find Mike Lindell
living there.
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
...he needs a place
to hibernate for the winter,
just like, you know, da bears.
But that's...
[ Laughter ]
...how you know things are
not going well for the GOP
when they bust out the caravans
and start hyperventilating
about the border.
That's a sure sign of their
political fortunes in any poll.
That's what Trump did in 2018.
Didn't work.
But now they're doubling down
and trying it again.
In fact,
at that very same rally,
Trump actually took credit
for inventing the word
"caravan."
-What's the problem?
I said,
"Well, you won't take
these horrible convicts
and other people
that you released
into our country illegally,
and you put them in caravans."
I came up with that term,
by the way.
That was my term,
like "fake news"
and lots of other terms
we came up with.
"Crooked Hillary."
We came up
with "Crooked Hillary."
We came up with a lot of...
He's like Billy Joel, stopping
in the middle of an MSG set
and saying, "You know,
I came up with Piano Man.
Yeah, before me,
people had to say penis,
but nobody liked it 'cause
it reminded them of ding dongs.
Also, Italian restaurant.
That was one of mine.
Before, it was ristorante.
What do you guys want next?
What do you guys
want to hear next?
"Big Shot"? I don't care.
I get paid either way.
The problem for Trump
and his gang
is that they've already
tried this and failed.
Everyone is onto them,
which is now
why they're trying
to out-MAGA themselves
with increasingly ghoulish
and despicable acts
of cruelty
toward migrants fleeing
poverty and violence.
Which brings us to Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis --
you know,
grown-up Nelson Muntz --
and his grotesque scheme
to apparently lure migrants
from Texas onto a plane
so he could drop them off
on Martha's Vineyard
without telling them
or anyone else,
a stunt designed entirely
to curry favor with Fox News,
who he apparently
alerted beforehand.
You see, they thought
the people who live
on Martha's Vineyard
would freak out.
Instead, residents
and community organizations
scrambled without any notice
to provide aid and comfort
to the migrants.
-Tonight, the community
of Martha's Vineyard
coming together to provide
food and shelter
to 48 undocumented migrants,
women, men, and children
who landed on
the wealthy island Wednesday.
So this entire thing
was funded by Florida.
The flights were part
of the state's program
to transport undocumented
migrants
to so-called sanctuary cities.
Now, earlier this year,
Florida lawmakers,
they had set aside $12 million
for this transport program.
Looks like they're
starting to use it.
-And the $12 million, I guess,
is coming from the federal money
that came in for coronavirus.
-So congrats, Florida.
You just spent a bunch
of taxpayer money
on a stupid and repulsive stunt
that achieved nothing
except maybe some publicity
for Ron DeSantis's
2024 presidential bid.
And worse than that,
you gave the rich liberals
who summer on Martha's Vineyard,
another thing to feel
self-righteous about.
[ Laughter ]
"When I heard those
poor migrants had arrived,
I put on my Birkenstocks
and loaded my Tesla
with sandwiches and pitched in.
I'm not saying I'm better
than you, I'm proving it."
[ Laughter ]
Also, not to let you too inside
on how summer vacations work,
but most of the liberals
you hate left the vineyard
two weeks ago.
And I should know.
I'm one of them.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
I go to the Vineyard.
And you know where I was
during President Obama's
star-studded Martha's Vineyard
birthday party last summer?
Having dinner with my in-laws
'cause I wasn't invited.
[ Laughter ]
And not for lack of trying,
it should be noted.
But it's also important
to make a distinction
between the people who spend
their summers on the island
and people who live
there year round,
like the hardworking staff
at Martha's Vineyard
Community Services
who rose to the occasion
with grace and empathy.
Personally, I feel like DeSantis
could've put the money he spent
on this stunt
to better use in Florida
like their local community
service organizations.
Or, I don't know,
more traffic cops
to chase down seniors
doing 80 on the highway
in their golf carts.
Have you ever been down there?
Those people drive their
golf carts
like they're [bleep] Maseratis.
One time,
I pulled up to a light,
and an 85-year-old grandpa
in golf khakis
challenged me
to a street race.
Even their attempts to dunk on
Massachusetts residents failed.
Like when Ted Cruz
tweeted the quote,
Dems had activated
the National Guard
to interdict migrants
in Massachusetts
before it was pointed out to him
that the governor
of Massachusetts
is a Republican
named Charlie Baker,
who called up the guard
to provide temporary shelter
and humanitarian resources
to the migrants
on Joint Base Cape Cod.
It was such
an embarrassing mistake,
Cruz had to delete the tweet.
And then, to make sure
the tweet was fully deleted,
he said he had to find
the server
where all the tweets are stored
and go there in person
to physically remove the disk
from the hard drive,
a hard drive he claimed
was in Cancun.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Seems weird to me, but...
I mean, he's a senator.
You got to trust him.
Now, on top of the many ways
in which this stunt
was ghoulish and cruel,
NPR reported that the migrants
were also
apparently lured onto the plane
under false pretenses
and told they were
headed to Boston,
where they would get
expedited work papers.
Not to mention the fact that
when they were dropped off
on a remote island far away
from their court appointments
where they don't know anyone,
in an especially cruel twist,
they were intentionally
given only the most
rudimentary information
about where they were headed.
-Accounts from the migrants
who arrived last night
make it clear that they were
lied to again and again
and fraudulently induced
to board the planes.
They were told there was
a surprise present for them
and that there would be jobs
and housing awaiting for them
when they arrived.
This was obviously
a sadistic lie.
They also very intentionally
chose not to call ahead
to any single office
authority on Martha's Vineyard
so that even the most basic
human-needs arrangements
could be made.
Ensuring that no help
awaited the migrants at all
was the entire point.
They were provided with
a cartoonishly simple map
of Martha's Vineyard
and the United States.
-I dare you to give that map
and nothing else to Donald Trump
and let him find his way
around Martha's Vineyard.
[ Laughter ]
I guarantee you he'd end up
in Nantucket Sound
within half an hour,
begging a dolphin
to give him a ride
to Mar-A-Lago.
"Click, click, whistle,
click, whistle.
Excuse me, excuse me.
Click, click.
Excuse me.
Click.
Click, whistle.
Whistle, click.
Caravan.
I came up with that one."
[ Laughter ]
"Click, whistle."
The Republican Party
is an institution
built almost entirely
around spectacles
of cruelty and humiliation.
And that's how you know
they're desperate.
They're resorting to horrific
scare tactics
and grotesque stunts
in an effort to gin up
yet another election-year panic
about the border.
And by his own admission,
Trump just pulls this stuff
straight out...
-My ass.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up,
so to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your
voter-registration status
or to register to vote.